Відверто про булінг.
Українська реперка Аlyona Alyonа днями випустила трек про цькування у школі.
"Тикати пальцями,
... вони будуть тикати пальцями, хоча просто поруч пройти могли,
але ж як не тикати пальцями".
Сама співачка у своєму Інстаграмі відкрито
розповіла, як не просто їй було в школі.
Через зайву вагу над нею постійно насміхались однолітки.
Втім, якщо у шкільні часи відомої реперки підлітки
не могли захистити себе в суді, тепер все інакше.
З січня 2019 року почав діяти закон щодо протидії булінгу.
Згідно з ним, будь-яке психологічне, фізичне,
економічне чи сексуальне насильство, зокрема
із застосуванням електронних комунікацій, карається штрафами.
Станом на перше півріччя 2019 року Національна поліція
склала 211 протоколів за статтею "булінг
(цькування) учасника освітнього процесу".
Хоча, кажуть, самих звернень було в рази більше.
Чимало випадків не підтверджуються, або ж
підлягають іншим статтям, наприклад є не булінгом, а хуліганством.
Попри позитивну дію цього закону проблеми
виникають й тому, що він недосконало прописаний,
кажуть в організації "Батьки SOS".
Визначення булінгу різне.
В законі "Про освіту" і в Адміністративному кодексі.
Тобто в законі "Про освіту" булінг - це неодноразові якісь вчинки,
в Адміністративному кодексі немає слова «неодноразові" чи повторювані».
Фактично будь-який одиничний випадок може бути
розцінений як булінг, але покарання згідно з Адміністративним кодексом.
Згідно з минулорічним опитуванням проведеним
Дитячим фондом ООН (ЮНІСЕФ) майже кожен четвертий
український школяр зізнався, що став жертвою цькувань у школі.
Та життя підлітків нині проходить як офлайн, так і онлайн.
І часто знущання продовжуються у соцмережах.
Тож міжнародні експерти наполягають, аби
в національних законодавствах також було
прописане визначення та покарання за "кібербулінг" - цькування в інтернеті.
Як показали цьогорічні дані ЮНІСЕФ, від такого виду знущань
страждає більше підлітків - майже кожен третій.
Наскільки це неприємно знає 11-річна Аріна,
коли під її YouTube каналом почали з’являтись неприємні коментарі.
Погані коментарі, це було…
ледь до сліз мене довели цими коментарями.
Мені було дуже прикро і образливо, що мені таке пишуть.
Я стараюсь. Якщо їм не подобається, то нехай не дивляться.
Про образи в інтернеті дівчинка не одразу розповіла батькам.
А коли ті дізнались, самі не знали, як діяти.
Адже булінг відбувається поза школою.
Невідомо і те, хто цькує: дорослі чи також школярі.
Тож вирішили просто видалити відеоблог і
не повідомляти про випадок в правоохоронні органи.
Втім, навіть у таких випадках, юристи радять все одно збирати докази.
Ситуації бувають дуже різні, тому треба одразу,
якщо видно, що відбуваються нехороші речі,
що в подальшому це може вилитись в систематичні образи,
то треба, як мінімум, робити скріншоти, записувати.
За два дні відео Alyоna Alyоna набрало понад
триста тисяч переглядів та чимало схвальних відгуків.
Зокрема, за відвертість та те, що порушено актуальну для підлітків тему.
Свій травматичний досвід пережила й Аріна.
Почала вести новий відеоблог.
Мені завжди подобалось доносити щось людям,
робити їм гарний настрій.
І після такої історії не змогла від цього відмовитись.
Хоч дівчинка і поводиться в інтернеті обачніше,
налаштувала конфіденційність та самостійно
підтверджує кожного підписника, втім показувати
свій блог нам не наважилась.
Хвилюється, аби не прийшли нові кривдники.